Taylor Swift is launching a new digital
mecca for Swifties Plus Miley and Liam's
date night at the thor ragnarok premiere
happy hump day my peat balls while the
old Taylor can't come to the phone right
now the new taylor is spaced honey fans
to celebrate the launch of her new act
Taylor gave fans a first look at the
Swift life on Wednesday a social app
where fans of Taylor can't connect with
each other with Tay herself and
seemingly collect cat stuff plus they'll
also get exclusive content from the
music superstar now the app has actually
been two years in the making and get
this it's developed by the same company
responsible for Taylor frenemies Kim
kardashian-west and Katy Perry's mobile
games meanwhile Taylor is gearing up to
unleash reputation for follow up to the
massive 1989 on November 10 and sure he
has a couple shows on the books
Taylor's rep confirmed e.t she will play
two radio concerts in December for CBS
Radio so collector coins kids are
another pop-tart making moves Miley
Cyrus who sang during carpool karaoke
last night but it's not a voice that got
my attention
it's her big or should I say hi
confession series I mean I'm gonna tell
you points in your life I want you to
tell me I was going to say okay VMAs
actually zero
what's zero no zero I can't so if I go
on stage I get too scared but there must
have been something in your system
oh that's just me that's how scary I
that's how insane I am that's just
normal
wrecking ball video 10 you are hot when
you're on the ball high high as hell yes
well Miley looked pretty put together at
last night's premiere of Thor Ragnarok
she and boyfriend Liam Hemsworth made a
rare public appearance to support big
bro Chris eats he was also there and get
this Cate Blanchet who was in the movie
worked out everyday with Chris's
personal trainer to play the first ever
Marvel movie villainous hella
[Music]
with that costume on you were just the
baddest of bad I mean literally you look
like the toughest woman on the planet
what was it like and how did you
transform when you put on helis costume
yes well I I sort of became fit
I got fit for the first time in my life
and I worked with Chris's trainer for it
doesn't sound like a lot but 20 minutes
a day it sounds like nothing right but I
was exhausted before I even got on set
but it was it was an extraordinary
opportunity to you know to finally get
fit and also to work with Zoey Bell
who's the most extremities and wonderful
actress which is an extraordinary stunt
woman and so I learned so much
physically from working with those guys
it seemed like even the way you stood
was powerful in this movie like you look
at you and when you you're even walking
up you try wearing that rubber I mean
it's not what you could do you have to
mean it's got the it's got the inbuilt
breasts it's got the whole thing so a
lot of it was done for me by mayest the
costume designer Kate she scared you a
little bit in that outfit I mean she
looks incredible in this movie but does
she scare you a little bit first time
you saw her she scares me off screen you
know the idea of working with Kate it's
Kate it's Kate Blanchet you know and the
idea of having to kind of hold my own
and and and and be worthy of what she's
bringing to the to the screen is a
little scary but she's the warmest
kindest most open person and made me
feel like maybe had some right to be
there you know it's good she beats her
behind in real life I mean she looked
fierce I I gotta tell you I sort of came
in thinking I know that the stunt
routine the training regime and she came
in and did a hundred hours more than I'd
ever had done and it was a little
embarrassing how how good and prepared
she was
I thought you'd be glad to see me are
your boys impressed that mom can go out
there and kick butt and be a badass I
think I've bent a few brownie points but
you know they haven't yet seen the final
thing so I'm I'm still waiting for the
old clear well we'll have to wait until
Thor Ragnarok hits theatres November 3rd
to see just how bad a skate is but
thankfully for fans of Riverdale they
don't have to wait much longer to
reunite with those ridiculously
good-looking Archie Comics characters
because season two of The CW favorite
premieres tonight and with more scoop on
that get it because they drink
milkshakes oh good I mean so exciting
Riverdale premieres tonight what can you
tell us about it oh my gosh Danny first
of all it is absolutely insane now
season 2 will pick up right where we
left off in the finale
Archie's dad Fred Andrews was shot by a
mysterious hooded man now we don't know
who shot him but as judge has said in
this haunting voiceover this attack was
anything but rant about Luke Perry tell
me he's okay I can't tell you that you
just gotta chew him now actually just
got back from the Riverdale set in
Vancouver Canada and here's what
archiekins
aka kg Appa said lies ahead for his
character this season hey KJ hey you do
it yeah you again Archie's going through
a lot in season 2 he's got a lot of
emotional turmoil going on how would you
describe his mindset throughout the
beginning of the second season beginning
the second season I think it's the first
time we see a we see a completely
different side of Archie with first
seeing like the the dark side of achi we
never got to see him in there in the
first season so that was really exciting
when I first read that for the first
episode of season two I was really
excited to see that we're going in that
direction but it sure you can expect it
to be a lot darker you can expect to we
dive into the relationships a lot more I
think bischoff Archie and Veronica with
again what's pretty being shot there's
so many different parts of their
relationship that they're exploring and
that they're finding out about each
other and different like kind of
characteristics that are coming out and
then both that they're learning about
with each other and I think
I think the same with Jackie and Biddy
as well a lot of trials to be to be had
for sure
Oh things are eating up for Archie
Veronica in that shower you don't even
know now do you guys that it's just a
teeny tiny part of all the Riverdale
goodies that I will be bringing you all
season long on our new franchise
Sweetwater secrets now you can see it
after tonight's premiere I'll be talking
all about the show's steamiest scene and
a moment Jennie that everyone's going to
be talking about amazing stuff girl I
think man steady a bite you guys can
catch new episodes of Sweetwater secrets
every Wednesday here on e t--'s youtube
channel I got to do is hit subscribe and
while you're at it like and share this
video we're always tracking the biggest
trending stories but let us know what
you guys have your eye on I'm all ears
alright I'll see you guys smile gonna go
catch up on Riverdale